for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
in the last video we talked about the
electron configurations of monatomic
ions in the main group elements in this
video I want to do the same thing
talking about the electron
configurations and monatomic ions but
specifically for those in the transition
block so similar to the situations with
tin and lead that were discussed in the
previous video and unlike most the main
group elements transition metals often
do not attain or acquire a noble gas
configuration though there are some
examples scandium forms a 3 plus ion to
have a noble gas configuration and
titanium forms a +4 ion to get a noble
gas configuration that's not always the
case that with transition block elements
so when transition metals form ions they
usually lose all of their n electrons
and some of their N minus 1 D electrons
where n is just the highest energy level
in question so if we think about iron
but iron is right here in the transition
block will kind of highlight it in blue
it's right here it can form a +2 or a +3
ion so let's explain what's going on
there so Fe can go to Fe 2 plus plus 2
electrons so irons
electron configuration is basically from
all the way up to argon and then 4s 2 3
D 6 and it's orbital diagram is shown
here before us 2 is filled 3 D has 6
electrons in it so if it loses two
electrons which 2 electrons is it losing
what's going to lose the electrons from
the highest the highest energy level
which is 4 in this case it's going to
lose those two 4s electrons and so the
orbital diagram will look like this
it'll just basically lose those 4s
they're no longer there anymore so
what's left over for the configuration
is just 3 d 6 so that's the
configuration of the iron 2 plus ion
okay now what about for the iron 3 plus
ion so we're just gonna lose one more
electron so the configuration that we
start with for iron is still the same 4s
2 3 D 6
that's the orbital diagram for that
but now we're gonna lose three electrons
well which ones to renal lose we're
gonna definitely lose those 4s electrons
both of those but then we have of these
which is going to leave it's that one
that's paired up right to leave it
entirely half full so we're gonna have
this orbital diagram right because
having them all half filled is pretty
stable right and so the electron
configuration there is going to be 3d
five right because we lose those 4s
electrons both of those and we lose one
from the 3d okay so it lost all of its n
electrons or NS electrons excuse me I
can't believe I made that mistake and
some of their D electrons so in this
case has lost one D electron in the case
of forming the three plus ion but in the
case of the two plus ion I didn't have
to lose any D electrons okay so another
note to keep in mind is that when we
fill these orbitals when we follow the
Aufbau principle guidelines the 4s
orbital is filled before the 3d orbital
so we would kind of expect 3d electrons
to be removed first but they're not when
removing the electrons before s
electrons are removed before the 3d
electrons this is often just noted as
the first in and first out idea right
when removing the electrons the highest
n value is removed first right so 4 is
bigger than 3 so they leave first ok so
I hope that video was helpful thank you
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying